und zwar hat die cdu schatten senatorin
für das bildungswesen princesse aller
welt herr nächstes für berlin dann sein
wird wenn ihr cdu gewinnt sie hat gesagt
dass sie gerne hätte das mädchen und
jungen in manchen fächern wieder
getrennt unterrichtet werden also in
fächern zum beispiel die informatik in
naturwissenschaftlichen fächern sollen
doch bitte mädchen und jungen wieder
getrennt unterrichtet werden der grund
ist bedingt durch die unterschiedliche
entwicklung und durch die sozialisation
gibt es nicht wenige mädchen und junge
frauen die es als stärkend und
motivierend erleben wenn sie in it und
mathematischen fächern nach
geschlechtern getrennt lernen das sagt
prinzessin anna welttennis für mich ist
das anti feministische mädchen und
jungen aufzuteilen in verschiedenen
klassen wo kommen wir denn da hin und
vor allem wo hört es auf beginnend beim
gender jetzt hin zu getrennten klassen
wo wollen wir noch mit dem geschlecht
ins haus fein und glauben wir wirklich
das mädchen in physik anders gefördert
werden müssten als jungs ich bin der
meinung die meisten mädchen die ich
kenne sind mindestens genauso klug wie
die jungs die physik
[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen heute
abend hier seht ihr das denn hier am
tisch passen muss ich ganz offen
gestehen wenn das jetzt tatsache werden
soll dann können wir doch gleich die
taliban ausbau würde neben und deshalb
finde ich es einen irrsinn dass wir das
was wir gemeinsam machen dass man das
jetzt wieder brennen will und die das
spricht ja nicht für das das was die
damen wollen nämlich die
gleichberechtigung gleichheit und ich
sag mal das bauen das dem da die mädchen
sozusagen gleich gescheit sind wie die
jungs das ist doch selbstverständlich
wir haben mehr leitende frauen aber
nicht weil wir irgendwelche quoten haben
sondern weil die durch leistung in die
position gekommen sind dessen das ist
ganz wer spricht frau teresa auch nicht
ab also das muss ich noch mal sagen sie
sagt nicht dass frauen dümmer sind
sondern sie sagt mädchen hoeneß als
stärken und motivierend erleben wenn sie
getrennt sind es gibt aber ich habe
nachgeschaut keine empirische forschung
die das bestätigt also ich finde im
prinzip die idee
schulklassen zu trennen ganz gut aber
schlecht
du warst zu schnell nach sozusagen den
besseren und den schwächeren und die
besseren werden dann ihre neben
leistungsvermögen nach gefördert und die
schwächere in ihrem nicht regt an
schulen er auf das sozusagen die besten
immer das tempo der langsamsten
mitmachen müssen auf die idee zu kommen
die männer und frauen jungs und mädels
wieder zu denken das ist wirklich so aus
dem anderen seite taliban finde ich hart
aber es hat was davon wir dürfen ja
ich bin ehrlich gesagt fassungslos dass
das einer frau kommt das finde ich schon
mal schlimm und wir sind so also wir
kämpfen so viel für frauenrechte und
dann wollen wir wieder bei null anfangen
also in wirklichkeit fassungslos darüber
wie jemand so etwas tun kann also ich
finde mit ihren rechten hat das ja
nichts zu tun aber wir dürfen auf gar
keinen fall hinter das zurück was
bereits erreicht haben und ich kenne
diese jungs und mädchen klassen aus
eigener anschauung also es hätte mich
wahrscheinlich furchtbar genervt wenn
alle mädchen in physik besser gewesen
wären als ich was sicher der fall
gewesen wäre wir wissen ja heute dass
frauen die jungs gnadenlos abhängen
gerade in den naturwissenschaftlichen
fächern das ist eine entwicklung die mir
keine besonderen sorgen macht weil weil
sie mich nicht mehr betrifft aber es ist
natürlich schon so dass die motivation
einer gemischten klasse und die die
dynamik einer gemischten da sie für mich
eine andere ist als eine rein jungs oder
mädchen klasse dieses element sollte man
nutzen pädagogisch der gruppe sie waren
ja auf eine jungenschule jungen internat
sie können ihr eigentlich als einziger
in der runde glaube ich bericht wie ist
es denn nur wie jung sagt bei mir gab es
keine andere wahl ich war im jesuiten
kollegs sankt blasien und das war ein
internat nur für jungs und
nach mir dann später zwanzig jahre
später waren dann extern auch mädchen
zugelassen aber meine schwester war in
kloster wald in einem mädcheninternat
und das war selbstverständlich und meine
kinder wiederum waren im englischen
internat und da waren mädchen und jungs
zusammen also das heißt die entwicklung
ist weiter gegangen und jetzt wollen wir
wieder alles zurück entwickeln also dann
frage ich mich wo sind wir eigentlich
ich sag mal zuerst wollen morgen gleich
die gleichberechtigung und plötzlich
soll alles wieder zurück und dann muss
ich zu gestehen die mädchen waren immer
in der schule etwas besser weil sie
fleißiger waren die waren nicht so
wild und so weiter und die waren ein
bisschen haben die jungs angespornt
indem sie im prinzip bessere noten
geschrieben haben und so weiter und
waren sozusagen die vorbilder für die
jungs und das würde ich schon sehr
positiv das hat mich jetzt auch
fasziniert was sie als unternehmer
gesagt haben der bestimmt nicht da herz
jesu mäßig seine seinen chefposten
vergibt auch die es so nett dass die
leistung der frau überzeugt und da bin
ich eben auch der meinung dass das ja
der motor der gleichberechtigung sein
muss eine leistung die erbracht wird und
nicht ein proporz der abgerechnet wird
ja das ist ganz wichtig ich sag mal wir
haben mehr leitende frauen aber nicht
durch quote sondern durch leistung und
zwar ich würde frauen nicht durch männer
ersetzen wo ich sage die sind so topp
dass ich sage das wäre fatal wenn ich
plötzlich aus quoten gründen man rein
setzt sich für die frankfurter drop
überhaupt nicht weil ich sage die
brauchen wir nicht frauen sind gut und
haben ihre ihm auch in der vergangenheit
meine großmutter war das sozusagen mein
großvater hat die firma gegründet sie
war 50 prozent beteiligt mein großvater
hat die firma geführt und wenn er dann
nach hause kamen dann war das regiment
bei meiner großmutter und sie hat
bestimmt was er anziehen muss was
gegessen hat und sie hatte die erziehung
der meiner mutter und meiner tante als
der beiden töchter das war die aufgabe
meiner großmutter und das waren
gravierende aufgaben und die sind
verteilt und warum wollen wird die
leistung die die einzelnen bringen und
wollen wollen wir nicht etwas trennen
und sagen die ist hier besser im
fachwissen und dir ist er besser im
fachwissen oder er ist kräftemäßig
besser das passt besser zu ihm
selbstverständlich trage ich einen
schweren koffer er als meine frau ich
meine bei der gleichberechtigung würden
müsste man ja sagen die soll deren kopf
selber tragen wir haben denn die damen
immer hofiert ist so wahr ich erzogen
man hat ihr den stuhl weg geschoben zum
sitzen man hat erst angefangen zu essen
wenn die dame angefangen hat zu essen es
war es war eine höflichkeitsfloskel
und das muss ich sagen das sollte wieder
zurück die gesetzt das war früher besser
als das was heute wie haben die damen
immer hofiert das ist eine der sätze die
in den sozialen medien um die ohren
fliegen also das ist
genau was gemeint haben wir wissen auch
genau was sie sagen wollen aber es gibt
eben ganz genügend viele die die sich
jetzt satt wird eher mäßig und so weiter
ausbreiten die es eben anders sehen
wollen und diese zur lachnummer machen
weil sie sagen darauf wird einer die
damen das ist das ist das hört sich
anders an als es gemeint ist ich
verstehst du verstehst es wir alle
verstehen uns weil wir verstehen wollen
aber interessant ist wie verstehen sie
dann also darf man da noch sagen dass
damals das macht es euch auch schon
sozusagen irgendwie noch einmal meine
damen und herren es ist also wie ist es
denn wirkt es irgendwie retro auf mich
auf mich überhaupt nicht aber herr grupp
und ich sind uns war heut ist erst mal
persönlich begegnet haben aber auch
schon öfter telefoniert bei diversen
einzigen aus zehn minuten das dann meist
fast ich wollte dass sie aufpassen weil
30 minuten bei einer stunde ist es dann
doch meistens in gekommen weil ich finde
ja zum beispiel ich sehe es eher so ich
finde alte weiße männer das nicht
diskriminieren das ist ja etwas wo sie
dann auch ins raster fallen würden bei
vielen feministinnen ich würde eher
sagen alte weise männer ich finde es
überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn sie sagen
dass man da mutiert hat und ich gehe
auch gerne zu ich mag es auch wenn mein
koffer getragen würde nicht mal viele
sachen die sie angesprochen haben auch
gern ich mag auch gerne wenn mir die tür
aufgehalten würde und der mann danach
mehr als rein geht aber wie es ist bei
dir ich sehe es genauso aber ich glaube
man muss differenzieren zwischen jetzt
privatleben und job weil ich finde ganz
klar dass man durch leistung überzeugen
muss und dass man da nicht um wieder
zurück zum thema zu kommen nicht die
klassen trennen muss weil er jetzt ein
junge und ein mädchen sitzt sondern den
ansatz fand ich tatsächlich viel
spannender nach leistung zu trennen also
wie gut jemand ist und ich finde so
sollten wir überzeugen und dann wäre
eigentlich auch eine frauenquote völlig
also völlig egal wie die gar nicht
bräuchten auch sicher wie bei der
anderer meinung muss ich ja sozusagen
auf den ersten überlegen wir haben ja in
unseren schulen wirklich andere probleme
oder politiker wird eine scheidung sagen
herausforderungen als wir am praktisch
eine digitale wüste da wir haben wir
schneiden in ein bildungs rankings
irgendwo ganz weit unten ab als das land
der dichter und denker oder einstmals
das land der dichter und denker und dann
kommt daher und schlägt als einen ein
mittel die schule zu verbessern
sozusagen die teilung nach geschlechtern
wieder fragt man sich schon ob es noch
geht also ich würd sagen bei dem thema
sind wir uns alle einig wir sind alle
fünf das kann man wohl sagen dagegen
dass die schulklassen voneinander
getrennt werden junge und mädchen
[Musik]